hi I'm Brianna from free code camp and
today we're going to talk about the
basics of computer hardware computers
are made up of four basic parts the
input/output CPU and memory the input is
what you're putting into the computer
think about mouse keyboard microphone
anyway you're giving data into the
computer the output is what you're
watching on your monitor or listening to
on your speakers these can both be any
format like text numbers videos images
what have you it doesn't matter the CPU
stands for central processing unit and
that's what we all think of when we
think of a computer
it's what does the functions it's what
runs a software it manipulates the data
the memory is where we store data and
information now the CPU has exclusive
access to this memory you can get to the
memory from the input or from the output
without the use of the CPU so just
review we've got four basic parts of a
computer the input/output CPU and memory
in addition to those four basic parts we
have three more things we're going to
discuss today the motherboard expansion
cards and power supply the motherboard
is what connects everything while the
data is flying around over here trying
to figure out where to go the
motherboard helps route it so it goes to
the right place
expansion cards are sound cards video
cards that kind of thing that can really
up your experience as a user power
supply is as it sounds what gets power
to the computer it's usually a part of
the computer that has that fan on it to
keep it from overheating so let's do a
quick review in addition to the four
basic parts of input/output central
processing unit and memory we usually
have a motherboard expansion cards and a
power supply
we're going to talk about the different
types of computers the biggest type of
computer we're going to talk about is a
supercomputer which maybe you've heard
of a supercomputer uses a whole bunch of
CPUs and uses something called parallel
processing all of those CPUs work on the
same problem at the same time the next
type we're going to talk about is a
server a server holds and accesses a
bunch of data or programs our website
free code camp is hosted on a server
which stores all that information next
let's talk about a workstation computer
now a workstation computer just looking
at it might look similar to a personal
computer but it has a bunch more power
and is way more expensive Toy Story was
built on workstation computers now
personal computers by far the most
common type of computers maybe you've
heard I'm a Mac I'm a PC something like
they're different but really this map is
still just a PC it's a it's a personal
computer it's still a book the Mac and a
PC the last type of computer we're going
to talk about is a microcontroller
microcontroller that's the type of tiny
computer you might have in your car that
has a really specialized task and is
really good that one small thing but
it's not like you could use it like a
regular personal computer so just to
review 5,000 computers supercomputer
server workstation PC and
microcontroller
we're going to be talking a little bit
more about the motherboard now the
motherboard we mentioned briefly we're
going to go into a little bit more
detail today so what makes a motherboard
is the connection between the CPU and
the memory if there's no connection
between the central processing unit and
the memory we can't call it a
motherboard but most motherboards do a
lot more than that primarily they have
expansion slots and ports now expansion
slots are where you put anything that
can increase the performance of the
computer without putting more load on
the CPU for example a graphics or a
sound card would up your user experience
by giving you a better video or better
sound quality but it wouldn't slow down
anything that the CPU had to do a
network interface card could also go in
an expansion slot this would help your
computer connect with the networks
around it we'll talk about networks a
little bit more in videos coming up now
a PC card which has really been turned
mostly over to Express cards are found
primarily in laptops because of the size
Express card is better it's just much
smaller in addition to expansion slots
motherboards have ports now on your
computer I'm sure you know there's a
place where you can plug in a USB cord
firewire SD card Ethernet even an audio
plug in so you can listen through
headphones now these are all considered
ports a place on the motherboard where
you can connect the CPU to some outside
source either to get or give information
so just a quick review of the
motherboard at its very minimum connect
the CPU and the memory but it also has
expansion slots and ports
and we're going to talk about the basics
of software we've already covered
hardware which are parts of the computer
that you can actually see and feel with
your hands software are the programs
that run on the hardware you can't pick
up a piece of software you can pick up a
piece of hardware with the software
downloaded onto it but software is the
code that is written and imprinted on to
hardware the two main types of software
that we're going to talk about are the
operating system like Windows Mac or
Linux those are the main three you're
not really gonna get any more than that
or applications now everything that you
think of a software probably falls into
these two spaces especially the
applications applications cover
everything from your web browser to
games to things like Photoshop or your
mail how you edit documents every type
of system application that is not an
operating system is just a regular
software application the big takeaway
from this video is that hardware is what
you can actually hold on to from a
computer but software consists of all
the programs that you can run on that
hardware
now binary code is a really really basic
simple computer language where there's
just once and there zeros there's by two
things
ones and zeros ones meaning on zeros
meaning off so think of like a light
switch which in some cases in super old
computer there was an actual switch
which was either on or off one thing on
0 being off so bunch of ones and zeros
they can mean pretty much anything but
really they're mostly meant to be
numbers and letters we're gonna go in a
little bit on how you actually decode
binary or translate a number to binary
code but really as you guessed you can
usually just google binary translator
and have that figured out the most
important part of this do you understand
the concept that even basic things like
zeros and ones can translate it but
something really really complex and is
the basis for all of the computer
languages and programs that exist today
we're gonna start by labeling starting
backwards how many numbers there are
this will be 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 pretty
straightforward so far the next step
that we're going to do is take two to
the power of whatever places so here
it'll be 2 to the 0 2 to the 1 - 2 - 2
to the 3 you get the picture
all right now that we got the 2 to the
given power figured out all you gotta do
is fill in some links and we'll have our
solution 2 to the 0 is you got it 1 2 to
the 1 is 2 2 to the 2 is 4 we've got 8
16 32 64 and that just keeps going on on
next what we're gonna do is see okay
which one of these numbers do we keep
alright so the next step figure out
which numbers do we keep do we just add
up all the things together and if these
were all ones then yes we would but some
of them are zeros the zero is the same
thing as like an off switch one being on
zero being off so we can go ahead and
cross all of these out right here
because they're they're not gonna really
matter we want to keep this one this one
here and here because they have the
corresponding ones which means yes it's
on we want to keep that number basically
from here on out we're just gonna add
these four numbers together getting us
we've got 70 Tuesday for 75 so this
number in binary means 75
we're gonna be talking about data size
the smallest size of data you can
possibly have is called a bit now that
is I wrote a one here that's an example
of a bit it can really either only be a
one or a zero it really goes back to
that binary that we were talking about
one me non zero meaning off it can
either be a one or zero that's a bit
bigger than that we've got a nibble
which is four bits it's not very
commonly used but it's adorable
I'm bigger than that we've got a bite
now this is common referring to
something in a byte it is an eight bit
put together now a lot of binary things
are expressed with eight bits like
letters and symbols and one most numbers
really can be expressed that way until
you get two really big ones so our most
basic data sizes you got a bit and a
byte but as you can guess it gets much
bigger than that
all right so after we get past the
regular small bit and the first little
byte which is eight bits we get bigger
really fast the next step up is a
kilobyte which is 1,024 bytes which
times eight is a whole lot more bits
after the kilobyte we've got megabyte
which is 1,024 to power of two which is
the same thing as 1,048,576 bytes so
since we're growing exponentially that
is a big big increase after megabyte
we've got gigabyte also known as GB
which is 1,024 to the power of 3 then TB
terabyte 1,024 to the power 4 and PD not
peanut butter it is henna byte 1024 to
the power of 5 just to give you an idea
of how big this number is if you can't
see it I almost ran out of room writing
this on my whiteboard these are some
pretty big numbers we're dealing with
here
you probably recognize megabyte gigabyte
terabyte from regular storage that
you've dealt with before on your iPad
your iPod your computer or anything like
that
alright just a quick review bit tiny
little either 1 or 0 byte 8 bits
kilobyte 1,024 bytes after that
everything is an exponent off of 1024
going from kilobyte to megabyte to
gigabyte terabyte all the way up to the
petabytes
we're gonna be talking about data speed
davis speed unlike data size is usually
measured in bits per second whereas size
is measured in bytes big difference
being bytes is eight times bigger than
bits at the very smallest level once we
start talking exponentially that makes a
really big difference how we talk about
speed kind of depends on what we're
talking about when we talk about the
speed of like an audio download we
talked about kilobits per second
kilobits not kilobytes totally different
number today we're talking about an
internet speed like the speed that your
internet service provider gives you
they usually measure that in megabits
per second so 1 million bits per second
the network speed is something we talked
about in gigabits per second so a
billion bits per second biggest
distinction here bits versus bytes data
speed is generally measured in bits data
size is measured in bytes another thing
we want to discuss just because they
have an internet speed that says you get
a certain amount of download that
doesn't mean you're gonna be able to
download that many bytes per minute per
second that's just not gonna happen
they're talking about bits it's gonna
take you a little bit longer to do that
since your data size is dealing with
bytes
we're going to be talking about the very
most basic level the computers can
understand other languages like
JavaScript the most basic thing like
we've already talked about is a bit up
or down 1 or 0 on top of that we've got
the biked 8 bit but together all letters
numbers and symbols can be broken down
into bytes that the computer can
understand at the most basic level so
that means all of the letters and
symbols that you're using in your
JavaScript can be translated into byte
now there are a lot of languages that
the computer uses at the most basic
levels to run just the operating system
but what I want you to get away from
this lesson is that everything in your
computer boils down to binary bytes
we're going to be talking about data
networks you've heard of networks before
maybe a wider network a road network
even a television network or a cell
phone network today we're talking about
data networks which are the networks
that computers use those three types
we're going to cover in this video are
the local area network the wide area
network and the Virtual Private Network
a local area network is just a small
group of computers that are connected
together the most important thing about
a local area network is that those
computers are close together so your
Wi-Fi at Starbucks or at a school that
is local area network that you can only
connect to if you're actually close to
that a wide area network is two local
area networks that have been connected
over a long distance so maybe a school
in Colorado wants to connect with the
school in Missouri they could use a wide
area network you might think that those
are connected over the internet and in
the case of a virtual private network
which accomplishes basically the same
thing as a wide area network it is VPNs
use the Internet to connect there to
local area networks however a wide area
network will usually rent a cable from
an Internet company and connect that way
so just to review a local area network
is a group of computers connected close
to each other a wide area network in a
virtual private network are two local
area networks or more than have been
connected over long distances the wide
area network accomplishes this by
renting a line from an Internet company
and a virtual private network does it
over the Internet
we're going to be talking about the
internet part 1 how the internet works
to know how the internet works we're
going to talk first about IP addresses
you might be familiar with the fact that
each of your devices has its own IP
address just like a house or apartment
has its own actual address the internet
can't deliver data to a device unless it
has an IP address not only does your
device have an IP address but so does
the modem and the router and every step
along the way in the internet which
we'll get to later IP addresses are
determined based on location starting in
five big international regions that's on
this side as you get down the line each
of these numbers brings you to a more
specific location now this number isn't
specific enough that you could call 911
your IP address and they could find your
house but it is specific enough where if
you google find the best Ice Cream
Sandwich near me Google can help you out
there and actually give you something
close to your location what I want you
to take away from this video is that
every device that connects to the
Internet has an IP address and that it
needs that IP address the information
knows where to go
let's talk a little bit more about how
the internet works we've already
established that every device and every
other thing along the way in the
Internet has its own IP address now
these IP addresses are assigned based on
location using these IP addresses your
device can talk to your modem which you
probably have in your home then to a
router which is set up by your web
service the router would go to the
domain name server this is still just
sending a request now that domain name
server would send back the information
that was asked for and it would go right
back to your device now you might think
this is pretty fallible if one of these
steps goes out the whole process is done
but really there's so many more
connections with so many routers and so
many servers is if one huge chunk of the
internet goes out that still won't
really affect the functionality of
anything else there are just intimate
connections it's amazing now what I want
you to take away from this video is that
your device since it has its own IP
address can send out a request for
information that information is sent
back to your device the way it gets to
your device is because of the IP address
and the way it gets there is through all
the lines of the modems and routers and
servers that make up the Internet
we are going to talk about something
called a CDN and a content delivery
network now the concept of a CDN isn't
that hard to wrap your head around what
the CDN does is make a faster and
smoother user experience by delivering
content to the user faster it doesn't
have to go through all the channels of
the internet it creates a faster and
more direct route from the site to the
user when I first was learning about CD
ends I got really confused because I
thought well doesn't everybody benefit
from that who's paying for the service
is that the user they'll pay for a CDN
to make their internet faster or is that
the website that pays a CDN to deliver
their content and it's the latter a CDN
is hired by a website or in some cases
developed by a website it's it's own CDN
then that CB n pays an internet service
provider to help determine the fastest
routes now what you need to know about
CBN's in the big picture is they are
hired by sites or created by sites to
make the user experience faster an
example of a CDN that you should know
about as a developer is how Google hosts
languages like jQuery if you link to
jQuery from Google's library instead of
uploading it yourself to your site
that's going to be way faster for your
user additionally if another site has
used that same CDN for jQuery it might
be stored in that users browser so it
doesn't even have to load again all as a
user you need to know that CD ends are
everywhere you probably use CD ends all
the time without really even needing to
be aware as a developer it's important
for things like the languages that are
hosted on Google libraries you can use
those in your sites and create a much
faster user experience with less work on
your end than before as a big company
you might need to see the end to do
something specifically for you you might
want your site to be on the fast track
to your users and you might need a CDN
to do that all I want you to take away
from this video is that CD ends are
content delivery networks they are all
over the place
and
they make a faster user experience
we're gonna talk about analog versus
digital on a really basic level most
specifically we're going to talk about
how computers interpret an analog sound
and turned it into a digital file an
analogue sound wave would look something
like this this would be like a perfect
sine wave which would not really ever be
heard of nature but that's beside the
point this analog sound wave the
computer takes that and measures at all
these different points measures those
and turns those into numbers based on
this point right here so we could go up
and say oh this is point two seven says
point one six and this is negative one
point two later the computer could take
those numbers and reinterpret them and
turn them into actual sound again we're
also going to discuss a little bit of
data compression how computers compress
data that is the sound file and image
file or a video file now the benefit of
compression is that it's a smaller file
so it's easier to store it takes up less
space and it's easier to send to
somebody else one of the ways this is
done in sound is it would take it less
often the sampling would be every two or
every three another way is that it would
just go up to here and say okay this is
point two seven well we're just gonna
measure everything from here so it's
negative three negative two negative one
from there if everything was around that
same area in images this is done by
taking the little tiniest possible
pixels and just measuring it in groups
of sixteen and finding kind of the
average color of that the most important
thing to take away from this video is
you're gonna want to use digital files
they're gonna have a better quality and
when you're looking at compression you
really need to look at how far you're
willing to go to ensure that the user
still has the best experience
we are gonna talk a little bit more
about routers and how they relate to
networking routers are the things that
connect different small area networks I
want to give kind of a metaphor for this
so I'm a teacher I work at a school
let's say I have a package that I need
to get to somebody that works in the
district offices I don't know where her
office is exactly but I know her name I
go to my secretary that would be this is
me this is my secretary
I go to my secretary I say hey I need to
get this to so-and-so at the district
office can you please help me out here
she'll say oh sure I don't know exactly
where her office is here but I know how
to get there I know the next step so
even though I didn't know the next step
she does so she goes on and sends it on
to the secretary of the district office
now that district office secretary has
no idea who I am or where I am but she
knows the end location what I'm trying
to get across here is each router only
has to know its own little network only
the stops right next to it it doesn't
have to know the whole internet just has
to know its own connections and it can
take information and say all right I
don't know exactly where that's going
but I'll pass it on to the right
direction and that's really all it takes
routers can be different sizes different
capacities but what they do is just know
their own neighborhood take the
information and pass it on in the right
direction another really powerful thing
that we're going to get into a little
bit later is they don't have to have the
full package of information either if
this computer is trying to send
information all the way up here
it might get split up and go to two
different routers and that's ok the
computers are still going to know how to
put that information back together
correctly now the little pieces of
information that are sent are called
packets packets are actually little
pieces of binary code which I'm going to
draw up here for you alright so this is
an example of what a packet might look
like it's just this line that goes up
and then down and up and down and is
either up or it's down that is an
electrical current so a computer gets
back and can translate that into ones
and zeros which we all know is a binary
code the way it does that is it
drivelines a certain distance apart
basically and if it's up is the one if
it's
it's a zero as we discussed in previous
videos this one and zero business can
really mean a whole lot more fact it
means everything everything can be
translated into ones and zeros so this
is really powerful
um these little packets are sent across
through these routers and sometimes if
there's a file that's too large for one
packet it can be broken up into frames
or smaller little packets these packets
don't have to go the same route they go
whichever box available whichever stacks
just and since they have the end IP
address encoded into them all the
routers know where to send them when
they get to the end destination that
computer knows how to put it all
together